[Music]
hi everybody i'm josh welsh president of
film independent and welcome to a very
special edition of film independent
presents uh before we get started i want
to thank uh our series sponsor the hfpa
and i want to thank hulu uh specifically
for making today possible
um today we are joined by the cast of
hulu's new series conversations with
friends i thought that maybe i wasn't
capable of love
i thought there was something wrong with
me
that isn't true
i know they're married oh i thought he
was funny
you have a crush on her
obviously i have a crush on her
i have this impulse
to be available to you
all the time
i'm in love with you and you obviously
don't feel the same
lately i feel like i'm watching you
disappear
i don't think i thought about the
reality or
consequences
[Music]
please join me in welcoming uh
actors joe allen sasha lane allison
oliver and jemima kirk thank you all for
being here thanks for having us great
great to see you all and i just let me
just start with some gushing i uh binged
the show very quickly i love it so much
i'm a huge fan of sally rooney and
all of her work and i thought this
adaptation was
so beautifully done and i'm really happy
that to have the four lead actors here
today because
i mean it's beautifully directed and
shot and everything but truly i feel
like this is an actor's tour to force
and it's the relationship between
your four characters that's really the
heart and soul of the show so
i just want to dive in and talk to you
all about sort of how you how you came
to the project and and your experience
of making it um i mean maybe i i feel
like this is a very obvious question but
i'll start with it which is what
when did each of you get involved in the
project and what drew you to it um
jemima may be starting with you yeah um
i got involved it must have been
sometime in the fall of
2020 or 21 2020 um
and i had just
wrapped up making another show
uh and i was i remember i was doing a
my audition was a uh i was at some
retreat because i'd just been shooting
for like five or six months on this
other show and i needed
to relax and just have some time to
myself and i but i had to do this
audition over zoom
um while i was there so i remember doing
that like with my juice and you know
like the zen music going on in the
background with other people doing yoga
and whatever
and um
and as i was doing this uh doing the
audition i was thinking
shit i really like this
damn it like
like i just wanted a break
and now i and i just i was like
and now i really hoped that i was gonna
get it which i also is a feeling of
vulnerability i don't like don't enjoy
um
so
you know i i found out i got the part
the next day
so
short wait
joe how about you what did you have a
similar zoom audition or what was your
into the series and what drew you to it
i was a no spa unfortunately um
i
had read um the book when it came out
and first and foremost was just like a
big fan of sally rooney and her writing
um i loved both of the books at the time
when they came out and um
was also a huge fan of lenny abrahamson
the director and his work so it was kind
of like a no-brainer to be a part of but
they they asked me to
audition um
and it wasn't over zoom or anything it
was just making a couple of tapes i
think there were three scenes i made
tapes for
and it was a pretty quick turnaround i
think um i think they had just
cast allison perhaps a week before and
um and i yeah i made some tapes and uh
and then they kind of gave the thumbs up
and um and very quickly after that lenny
kind of invited um
me and everyone on board to kind of
open up discussions about what we
thought of the scripts he was very
collaborative and wanted feedback and um
but that yeah i guess that was around
like early october 2020.
it was so nice to have him
to have lenny trust us so early on
you know like i remember that same that
same conversation right like so quickly
after i got the part it was like right
okay here's my questions this is lenny
to me here's my questions you know he
had questions for us
that to hear our takes on it which is so
refreshing and and exciting to be like
really my ideas yeah i got a ton you
know
um
yeah it was collaborative that's great
sasha um so your character is a
departure from what's written in the
novel and that she's an american in
dublin and uh
what was your how did you get into the
project and did they reach out to you
was that something you
sought out and and what drew you to it
um
i
i just got like the the normal email of
like you know we want you to audition
for this and they're interested um and
then i read the book
um at at that time as soon as i got the
email because you know i knew i was
gonna have um i was gonna do a self tape
and then
lenny asked to speak with me which i
thought was great always like talking to
the director beforehand because it kind
of gives me an extra sense of like
confidence i want to know you know just
how passionate are you about this
project what are your thoughts on this
project um
on top of my own and
funny enough then i guess just kind of
like off of what jemima said the first
conversation i had with lenny
just before i was about to then do
a audition with alison was
so what do you think like do we think do
you think we make her like this it just
if oddly enough felt like as if he's
handing you the project when it's not
yours because no matter what he still
wants to hear your thoughts he won't you
know and so we talked about whether or
not we would make her american which is
funny because then
you know there's other people
auditioning obviously and i don't know
if he's having different conversations
with them and how they view it and so
just instantly start to fall in love
with the process from the get-go because
you know that you're going to be able to
voice your opinions you're going to be
able to to talk more you know i had
maybe what we had like three four scenes
to audition with um that i had with ali
and
when i moved along to the next process i
then went to ireland
to do another round of the chemistry
read and
i remember
adding they added like two more scenes
to audition with but i had already just
i was so into it at that point and and
the way lenny operates in that room is
it's not just here go your self tape and
here go your thing and moving on it's
very much like oh should we try it this
way should we try it that way and it it
just makes you want to work it really
does it gets you so excited
regardless if you get it or not you just
felt like i don't know i performed half
of this already so
yeah it's yeah he's it's just such a
dream i keep jumping in but i keep
having things i want to say that i
haven't said yet and i won't get this
might be one of our last interviews so i
don't get get to say it but it did feel
more like going to a class an acting
class every day than it did like going
to work
it felt like because of the the freedom
to make mistakes
and the freedom to try things and to not
be have a director go don't do that
never was that ever said don't do that
it was said it was a suggestion of why
that might not work but let's try it
this way and it wasn't kit we weren't
used with the actor kid gloves you know
which is
an actor can smile from a mile away but
it was uh it was just
it was just that it's so experimental
um
into not not necessarily on camera but
right before you know there was so much
discussion it felt like you were going
to class with people who loved acting as
much as he did
yeah
so alison i'd love to hear from you so
so from everything i read this is your
first role on on camera and how i'm
curious how how did they how did lenny
find you how did you find him in the
project and what was your audition
process like
um
yeah i was i was living in dublin at the
time um and i'd read both normal people
and conversations with friends and was
just
such a massive fan of sally's and
particularly with conversations with
friends that book just meant so much to
me when i read it and
and that was all it was for me you know
like it was just this thing i was like i
love this book so much and and had such
a relationship to it and and loved the
character so much
and then kind of almost separate to that
like i was already a massive fan of
lenny's for years like i've been you
know watching his films in ireland and
all that kind of stuff and and an
element the company who makes it a
really really well respected production
company in ireland and so
um when all of those three things kind
of came together like when i got an
audition tape
for that with those people it was just
like anything i
would ever dream of like i was just like
this is amazing and and i felt so lucky
to even when i was you know i think i
did about three rounds of auditions and
like what the guys are saying like i
think for my second round i had a zoom
with lenny
and like
just before like i remember sitting in
my room i'm being like oh my god
like lenny rimson's about to log on to a
call with me
and then within like the first 10
seconds he just completely puts you at
ease and like makes the most
collaborative
environment equal environment and that
what the guys are saying of like he he
makes it feel like a workshop and he's
like yeah like why do you think she
feels that way like do you think it's
because of this or like oh that's really
interesting maybe we should try it like
that then and like you know it's it's
yeah it's like an acting class and it's
and you feel so respected and kind of um
and and that i think one of you were
saying this yesterday that it feels like
he really gives you that space that in
that moment when you're auditioning the
character feels like it's yours like you
know and that it's not like you know
show me what you can do it's like oh yes
let's rehearse this like in like this
character in your body and and
and yeah and so i did like
three auditions and on my last audition
that was like
just such like high stakes because i
just wanted it so much and i felt like i
really
understood that character and and just
really wanted to to work on it and so
and
when it when it finally kind of went my
way i was just like it was one of those
things i was like oh the best thing ever
now would be if i just got a phone call
and i just got told that i could do it
and then
and then when those things happen you're
just like
yeah it was it was the best thing that i
think could have could have happened so
and that was kind of yeah my journey to
it so were all of your audition because
of covid were all your auditions online
or did you have the opportunity to do
anything where you're acting opposite
each other in the room
um i think it was just
me and sasha who acted opposite each
other in the room i
my third round audition was in person i
was with lenny and then i came and met
sasha and when she was doing her
audition but apart from that everything
i think or maybe joe were you on you
were just on self tape aren't you and
and and
but we were actually talking about this
earlier like how much you actually can
get from zoom it's kind of amazing the
even though you're kind of you know
communicating through a computer
actually you can get so much of i guess
maybe for people auditioning an essence
or an energy of of what you're looking
for in that character it really
translates actually in a way so and it
luckily worked i think i mean honestly
it's incredible to hear that that's how
you all audition because what comes
through in the series the most striking
thing about it are the
the connections between the four of you
and the the degree of intimacy and the
believability of the relationships and
the
um
you know what what i love about the show
more than anything is that there's like
with all four of you there's this sense
of constant discovery like across the 12
episodes i felt like i was constantly
learning new things about the characters
even more than that it's that you all
are learning about more about yourselves
and each other throughout the thing
there's no sense of like a rigid
well-defined character in the first
episode who kind of plays out through
the series
it's very mercurial and just
that's i feel like i just was leaning in
the whole time watching not knowing what
was going to happen between any of these
relationships
and then at every episode when some
development would come up be like well
of course that's what happened like it
there's a
beautiful emotional truth and
inevitability to it you know that i mean
i don't know i'm rambling here but i
it's nice
i think that this all started yeah i
guess zoom can really deliver a lot well
you're still talking to a person and and
i mean i think with acting and
especially with something like this
that's so intimate and i mean and i
don't mean internet necessarily
with people with each other but it's
also really intimate with the character
with yourself right with the characters
it's not just francis who has these
these isolated there's these isolating
emotional breakdowns
you know in her head i think everyone's
having them
um
except hers we're more privy to to hers
um
but yeah even so so i think the
challenge was for me with this was to
to get as
in as personal as i could
uh with my even just sitting there even
just if if i couldn't that day for some
reason couldn't grasp a moment in the
scene or was it struggling for that hour
i'd just be like okay
here i am in a chair sitting across from
allison right how does what are my
feelings about alison right now you know
and and that that because of the the
connections and the friendships we built
there was enough material there for me
to go on on any given day
um
ones and then and that's the
fun
and the beauty of acting is you get to
use things that you you ignore in your
head on a daily basis or choose to
ignore or try to run from you know you
get to play with those feelings that are
off limits
yeah
um
a question for allison and sasha both i
mean this i could ask this of any of you
but um just kind of building on what we
were just talking about and and what
jemima was saying i'd love for the two
of you to talk about
the that your relationship that
friendship and romance and the way it
plays out over
the series like i guess my question is
how do you build that over 12 episodes
where
there's so many different colors and
levels to that relationship
and you know there's there's a different
sort of
power dynamic or or levels of openness
that you have with each other and
they're you know shades of anger and
affection and it's like
like everything in the series there's
that mercurial alive quality to it
but it feels very
like it doesn't just feel it's not just
like
some chaotic thing that's happening on
screen it's like this beautifully
structured performed relationship that
you guys created and i'm just curious
how you obviously lenny's part of that
but can you talk about his actors how
you created your relationship over the
series
i think we had a few
discussions of um i think me and ali
would kind of just for the sake of it
with each other like
okay who do you think broke up with who
and how do you think she said it how do
you think you felt that moment and um
and that kind of gives you your basis
and then
we
thankfully in the beginning the first
week or two was pretty much just me and
ally in our scenes together in the
apartment and you know the beginning of
it when the relationship is good and the
beautiful thing about that was we got to
one
focus on more
lighter connection and you know just
them enjoying each other which
thankfully me and ali enjoyed each other
so that was you know easy enough and
then that's when you start to break down
we would say like how do you think they
are
intimate wise not even romantically just
when they sit on the couch together do
you think she leans on yeah dentist more
does bobby lean on you know does francis
lean on her do you think they
sit like an old married couple who like
don't speak and but yet like do not move
from the seat because you are exactly
where i want you to be and you know so
we just have little conversations like
that about
those small little details and
characteristics and and kind of like
uh
just just little little small things
that actually
are really really big when it comes to a
friendship in a relationship that has so
much history because that's how you are
with your own friends in your own
relationships where
i already know that if i grab a glass
i'm gonna grab two because you are gonna
want this wine you're gonna want red
today and you know you're
i usually pick the snacks and you pick
the movie and you know so that was kind
of fun in the beginning to be able to
discuss that and i think
since you have six months of filming in
12 episodes by the end of it
it's just like it's so easy or not easy
but it's natural you know you have it
already in the back of your mind
yeah i i think is as well like
i was really interested in i think we
were both really interested in exploring
that kind of like
female friendship but that was
definitely something that stood out to
me when i read the book and felt really
recognizable to me of like having
a best friend like a best girlfriend and
that kind of
really deep innate understanding of each
other what what it is to be like a a
woman and like and i think because they
have that added layer of um
like past romantic history and
there's kind of this unresolved tension
that's going on amidst being you know
inseparable best friends and so i think
like when we really kind of
distinguished their backstory uh and i
knew what that was and then and then
those little like details that sasha was
talking about like you know like who
buys the wine and who you know all of
those little things that would make you
really feel like you know this person
and that you have developed this way of
being together
then then we get to set off and see how
that dynamic shifts because of the the
kind of
situation that they find themselves in
and how do they
like in a sense what they go through in
this story is is
this
relationship with nick is the first kind
of new romantic partner that's
introduced like into their
dynamic and
and they've never dealt with something
like that before and
although they kind of identify as
friends when we meet them it really
uproots
repressed feelings that
you know that they have but haven't
addressed and so i think like
it was actually really interesting to
like
you know
kind of be flipping in between the two
the whole time of like um
am i feeling sad because i i miss you or
is it because i'm actually jealous
because i still fancy you or you know
like and and i think that's quite a
thing with women of like that kind of
line is so blurred sometimes in it kind
of a spectrum in a way that and sally is
able to write that really really well
and i think because me and sasha both
identified with that in our own way that
we could kind of just
you know step into that together and
explore it together so i and i felt so
lucky to do that with sasha because
you know i feel like you just yeah
is she's perfect
[Laughter]
well i mean it's a beautiful
relationship to see play out across the
series i i love
the whole
entirety of it um one thing that struck
me in the show i mean obviously this is
in other films and shows as well
anything contemporary but so much of
your communications throughout are on so
you're talking on the phone you're
texting or there's emails right it's
communicating through technology and
what struck me in this is well there's a
lot of it i mean it feels very realistic
it's how we communicate but um
it remained visually engaging which i
think is a the way it's filmed and the
way it's paced in
everything i think lenny does a really
great job with it but for you all as
actors
there are scenes where you're on the
phone or texting that are emotionally
powerful or they're funny or
moving
they're not just
you know dry technological scenes i mean
i'm thinking of like joe there's the
scene
there's a lot of these scenes but like
to
i don't know it might be in the last
episode where francis is telling nick
about when she could for the first time
telling nick about when she was in the
hospital
and i think it's that scene where you
start crying like your reaction is
you're really moved by what she says and
you you have this strong emotional
reaction which totally makes sense um
but i'm just curious for for you as an
actor and i'll open this up to others as
well but like
how was that how how do you go about
doing that what did this feel like um
was that a major part of how a
significant piece of this shit of
conversations with friends where you
were having to like deliver that level
of performance while you're on the phone
or texting somebody and how how do you
do that as an actor is somebody on the
other end feeding you the lines are you
doing it into the void
it was mainly obviously allison who has
to receive all the texts so she can
speak most of that but in terms of one
thing that we did do
on this which was lovely was you know if
there's a phone call then the other
person would be there at the other end
of the line or or crouched in the corner
of the room and so you weren't you know
it wasn't a you know an ad reading it in
or you weren't dialing it in from
a hotel it was kind of treated with the
same level that you would with any other
scene it wasn't glossed over and lenny
still wanted to
interrogate that as much as
you know were it visible um it wasn't
kind of short changed just because it's
on the phone um
i mean ali you can speak about it more
than me because because it was mainly on
you but
um but that was really
that was probably one of the first times
i'd had that like i think we were saying
the other day like normally you know
someone's
someone gets the day off and someone
else will just read in the lines but to
have the other person and the other
presents actually there
um makes a huge huge difference um
massive yeah it was really really great
yeah i think and we always had that we
all everyone you know showed up for each
other like that was always the case and
and
i was actually speaking about this you
know earlier and
uh like about the scene between um
francis and melissa uh when in episode
12 when they speak on the phone and and
kind of the massive weight of that i
mean i think it's the first time they're
just completely
you know
raw and really really honest with each
other and and
i think like there's something really i
found something really interesting about
you know how much of a phone is a shield
and a kind of it's in in between you and
the person you're speaking to in a sense
and that like
actually even dramatically or visually
on a screen like
you can see a character saying one thing
and but their face is doing another and
so i actually think it's a really
interesting kind of tool and
storytelling of like being able to see
how a person really feels on their face
but they might be saying something else
and like i certainly felt when i when i
did that scene with like to my man stuff
like we were i think we had like a whole
day to to do that scene and broke it up
into like two halves we shot both we
shot both sides in one day which is also
something we don't really do usually he
lenny always set it up that way so that
we shot the whole conversation in one
day
normally they chop it up and they do you
do one side of the conversation the
other it's just it's treated normally as
if it's not a conversation
with a scene between two people which it
entirely is yeah yeah and we were just
really given the space to like really go
for it and like really talk about it and
and actually just
feel it like you know sometimes things
on set can be really quick and sometimes
you just like i just don't feel it
because it's like there's all these
different things happening and actually
what lenny's so good at is like no they
need to just like actually go to like
you know feel this stuff and give them
the space to to
you know explore what the character is
actually going through and so like yeah
i i actually
in in a funny way i actually quite
enjoyed a lot of the phone stuff because
so much of and i think what lenny does
really well and leanne is
everything always has to be kind of in
opposition it's like two things are
always kind of happening at the same
time and i think sometimes when you're
doing things with phones
it's like
you know you might be saying one thing
and then your face is saying another and
so i actually found it to be quite an
interesting tool
in storytelling i think there's a lot of
hiding you can do behind a phone and you
can also hang up which is
you know i think when you're face to
face with someone you said you don't
have as much of a choice right to be in
the conversation i think it's to an
extent when you're on a phone you're
choosing to be in this in this conflict
but that the interesting thing about
that scene that we did
was when i started reading it with you
we shot alice inside first and i was in
the kitchen with her you know behind the
camera
and i just started sobbing reading it
and like i don't know why i did i mean i
do know why but it wasn't what i was
expecting
and or actually it was what i was
expecting but i knew it's not what was
being
what was on the page
and i it and so i was doing it anyway
because it wasn't on camera and i was
thinking i'll let this go and see if it
helps it see if it affects allison and
if they want to change they can change
it on my coverage but then at one point
i looked up and lenny had been staring
at me for an entire take
which i thought which i didn't realize
and then he then yeah he pulled us both
together and he was like okay
i see this a bit differently now
and it was
it was really nice it was just um it was
just a good example of where a phone
call is so
it's just as important as any other
scene i don't know why it's shot in such
a chopped up way
i mean that that scene really is
incredible it's like all the turns the
emotional turns in that conversation
from
i mean allison where francis starts out
to where she ends up is completely
different and
you know and and jemima there's this
moment where
you pull the phone away from your ear
hold it there
like what is going to happen is she
hanging up your butt it's just i don't
know it's this incredible moment thank
you i remember lenny talking about do
you remember this time where he said it
was like it's almost like two dogs and
the small one is like
like it goes in yeah and then the dog
turns around and it's like
just completely
don't even try and i remember that being
so helpful like thinking of like this
dog who thinks he's like you know gonna
like you know tell the person yeah yeah
no one's like well he always says he has
these anecdotes that lenny comes up with
are so helpful the one that sticks out
to me the most is one day there was one
moment where it's right after francis
and nick have kissed for the first time
and she's coming downstairs from the
party looking for bobby and she's clocks
and her and i lock eyes and we shot that
take a bunch of times because lenny
wanted the look to be right right the
the look between us with a look from me
really to be right and yours yours
you've got in a few takes mine took a
few more because and it was when he said
this one thing that it made sense he
said it's like
it's like when you're sitting at a group
of with a group of people at a dinner
table and you're all sort of friends or
acquaintances no one that intimate
though and all of a sudden you lock eyes
with someone
for a split second
and you're for that split second you are
intimate with someone you did not intend
on being intimate with you didn't plan
for it it just was an accident
and it's passing
and it's um it's briefly uncomfortable
it's briefly romantic it's briefly
sexual it's just brief brief briefing it
doesn't mean anything but it happens
yeah you know and he said that's what i
want and i i when he said that i was
like i told i got it i got it i gotta go
yeah oh god
um well i think i i'm i'm getting the
cue that we need to wrap this up but i
one more question i would love to keep
talking to you much longer but um
allison i have one last question for you
which is i'd love for you to talk about
the scenes with the your parents with
francis francis and her parents those
those scenes are so beautifully done and
unexpected and that i just like there's
a
where you start in those early scenes
there's a kind of coldness
or or sort of there's there's some
obviously so much history
and backstory that we're not told what
it is but there's something between you
and your parents that plays out in every
scene completely believably but also
mysterious i just like how did you as an
actor how did you approach that sort of
conveying that what that history is
without spelling it out
i'm so glad you asked me that because i
haven't talked about this at all and i
think
it's a massive part of why francis is
the way she is i i totally credit it
completely back to her relationship with
her parents she grew up in a household
where communication was not valued in
any way she also grew up with the father
who was totally unreliable um and would
kind of um
you know
she describes it in the book because he
would kind of
after he would you know have it have an
episode or get into one of his moods he
would kind of crawl back with with kind
of kindness and and and that kindness
kept getting abused and so she doesn't
really have great trust or great
communication and she's also i think
you know it talks about it a lot in the
book about
as that started to happen again and
again
and as he you know struggled with his
alcoholism and and she
she kind of had to decide from a very
young age how she wanted to deal with
that did she want to kind of really
you know
try and be a part of of of his life and
make him you know be nice to her or did
she want to just shut it out and go you
cannot hurt me and
like you know
if i just if i just become cold and i
don't let either thing affect me your
kindness or your your abuse and i you
know i i'm untouchable basically and i
think
that is totally why she is the way she
is when we see her in this you know when
she's older
and um i think with her mom like
because and it's that classic irish
thing of like you know we don't we don't
talk about it and we don't you know we
just kind of
things happen and it's you know it's all
fine and the parents separated and now
she goes and sees her mom but her mom i
think is a very traditional woman in the
sense of like he's your father you go
see your dad you you continue that
relationship because he's your dad and i
think francis is at that age where she's
really challenging those things of like
what why do i need to see him like what
like
do we have a relationship and do does he
value me and i think
through challenging all that stuff and
kind of
um
you know
growing up with everything else that's
going on in her life i think she sees
that you know her parents really aren't
superheroes they're you know they very
much make mistakes just like she's
making mistakes and i think um
you know certainly with her dad i think
she starts to realize
he's really not okay and and
she doesn't know how much longer he's
going to be around and so i think she
kind of really grows up in that moment
in episode 10 where he he kind of has an
episode and
and she kind of just goes you know what
i'm just gonna you know they're my
parents and i'm just gonna love them for
what they are rather than
constantly feeling resentful of what
they weren't or the childhood that they
didn't give me right
that's it
this final scene with your mother in the
bar
is that's a beautiful scene as well you
do it does feel like francis is more
open to her in that moment and there's a
moment where the the mother says i
forget the line but something like
you make decisions and hope you yeah you
hope and then the look on your face of
where you're just listening to her and
taking that in is it's just beautiful
acting it's just an incredible moment of
i don't know what's going through
francis's mind at that point but you're
clearly hearing what she said and it's
really having this profound impact on
you
um
anyway congratulations you all thank you
so much for talking i really enjoyed
this um i wish we could go longer but um
congrats for anyone watching this q a if
you haven't seen conversation with
friends go do it now
um and uh thank you all so much
[Music]